franck riester les producteurs de vins
français sont très inquiets une nouvelle
taxe qui de 25% qui était imposé par
l'administration trump est ce qu'elle va
vraiment être appliqué dans quelques
jours et est ce qu'est ce que vous
attendez sur ce dossier de ce conflit
commercial qui n'en finit pas entre les
états unis et l'europe
est ce que vous attendez la suite le
maiden il est le résultat vous savez de
ce conflit entre boeing et airbus sur
des aides de gouvernement du
gouvernement américain pour boeing et du
couvent et des gouvernements français
allemand et italien et anglais pour pour
airbus
nous ce que nous disons c'est il faut la
désescalade
nous avons aucun intérêt entre
américains et européens à faire en sorte
d'être dans une escalade de ba de 2,2
sur taxes douanières et donc nous
appelons les américains à la désescalade
pour autant nous voulons être respectés
parce que nous ne pouvons pas accepter
que les américains taxent nos produits
sont que nous nous taxons les leur
appartement nous nous sommes autorisés à
le faire par l'om sait c'est pour ça que
en fin d'année nous avons pris la
décision effectivement de réagir à la
politique de sur taxes douanières des
américains en appliquant nos propres
surtaxe sur boeing et sur les produits
américains un certain nombre de produits
américains
aujourd'hui enfin le 30 décembre une
décision qui a été prise qui était une
décision qui est absolument illégitime
illégale d'un point de vue du commerce
international par les états unis nous
contestons cette décision qui doit être
en application dans les prochains jours
notamment qui pénalisera les vins
français
un certain nombre de vins français et le
cognac et notamment des pièces détachées
aéronautique et donc nous sommes en
train de voir de quelle manière nous
pouvons réagir d'une façon très ferme et
aux partenaires européens mais nous
voulons là on est à 15 jours de l'entrée
en fonction de l'administration bynum
peut-être peut-être moins si on va voir
comment les choses vont évoluer là dans
les jours qui viennent mais enfin en
tout cas qu'un jour de l'arrivée de la
nouvelle administration bayane et dont
nous voulons est dans une démarche de
dialogue avec l'administration banide
pour que tout de suite il nous envoie un
signal fort de désescalade
joe biden a dit qu'il souhaitait renouer
une relation transatlantique
forte à nouveau de partenariat d'amitié
entre les etats unis union européenne
il a un bel belle opportunité de le
démontrer en retirant les sur taxes
douanières sur les produits
airbus est sur les autres produits
français européen et l'europe a dit très
clairement que si c'était le cas elle
retirerait elle aussi ses barrières
douanières
[Musique]